si une telle unanimité existe au
parlement syrien sait que dans ce pays
autoritaires il est de fait très
difficile de s'opposer au régime y
compris dans les universités où les
jeunes préfèrent ne pas parler de
politique en tout cas pas devant une
caméra
le discours est toujours très maîtrisée
reportage à l'université de hama à 200
km au nord de damas philippe denis qui
indique la syrie a beau être en plein
deuil national
les examens n'ont pas été reporté alors
les étudiants de rama sont en plein
travail ici
l'apparition d'une équipe de télévision
française a un peu surpris mais personne
n'interdit haha ces jeunes dont les
études sont financées par l'état de
s'exprimer simplement des profs vont
leur demande et d'épingler un badge sur
leurs vêtements
il y est écrit les étudiants de syrie
sont les soldats d'assad
de quoi créer un climat un peu
particulière présentant la charge
il faut améliorer tous les domaines de
la vie elle va continuer le travail de
son père quitte été parfait avec son
père il n'y avait rien de rien à
améliorer
rien du tout aujourd'hui
est ce que je peux vous poser une
question politique
pourquoi questions de politique de te
poser des questions de politique si je
peux répondre non voulait pas parler
vous n'aimez pas ça à rama il vaut mieux
éviter de dire un mot de trop en 82 la
ville a connu un mois d'émeutes les
frères musulmans des sunnites hostiles
au régime d'assad s'étaient révoltés
la répression aurait alors fait plus de
dix mille morts la ville a été en partie
rasée par l'artillerie
elle est aujourd'hui plein de policiers
en civil étudiants musulmans ramade ne
veut plus entendre parler de cette
histoire
moi je ne sais pas ce que sont devenus
les frères musulmans je suis jeune je ne
sais même pas ce que c'est que ce parti
ni ce qu'il voulait mais je n'ai aucune
relation avec ces gens là et je ne
soutiendrais jamais un mouvement qui
complotent contre l'êta après cette
interview ramade va tout de même
vérifier auprès du doyen de la fac
s'il n'aurait pas mieux fait de se taire
il n'y a aucun problème tu as dit la
vérité et puis on est dans un pays libre
tu as le droit de dire ce que tu ramat
sera visiblement soulagé d'entendre que
la syrie est un pays libre pour les
étudiants d'un ram a évoqué les pages
noires du passé ça n'est pas faire de
l'histoire c'est faire de la politique
et c'est ici un exercice périlleux alors
il se méfie du passé et préfère parler
de l'avenir avec prudence